welcome to this video yeah this is a new
rapid game twenty five and ten second
increment yeah I actually lost them I
think two games I mean sorry I mean not
losing in term time meaning losing the
game but I lost the recording and do to
with that said software problem that i
had so i actually gained some ground
here rating wise boomba should be five
that's a that's an uncommon way to play
this now why doesn't really want to take
with the bishop here on c6 and the move
a six in my guys somewhat on my agenda
anyway i can go away six and force them
to take sorry just the night move should
be fine as well yeah the time i love
Sicilian something that I want to why I
think about incorporating into my
repertoire interesting moment here we
should be six as an interesting move
attacking that pawn and maybe intending
to take their and Bishop b5 I have a six
with the temple that that makes it more
interesting and this Bishop is kind of
off side yeah maybe that's an interest
Edison it's an interesting idea not
completely sure about it but it's
interesting of course they don't intend
to keep the bishop there all the time
but it's a test some ideas that was a
secondary idea I have to admit 9450
quindi for Bishop c5 wins the night I
wins the Queen I'm sorry so I can take
him and win the game immediately
yeah that fresh rating pool is so giving
lots of mismatches admittedly if he goes
e5 yeah thats it's the only move that
poses some kind of a problem i can go
Bishop c5 this is one idea one gap also
90 x b5 nothing wrong with that hmm what
is the best way to do it it doesn't
matter really I guess it's both just
just two peas up check so yeah I'm
taking this on yeah just take that let's
see yeah he's attacking on one g7 yeah
the easiest is probably to just drop all
the way back and then recapture on g7 if
he takes them
he's not taking it okay yeah then I will
do so yeah understandably he wants to
open the position okay probably just
here covering f6 if you take some okay
that now i will keep the stuff closed
yeah if it's more like a blitz game but
right after the opening or right in the
opening he had some blundered blundered
that piece so this is very easy to play
now you probably just take him white
resigns yeah okay oh we have to go
through that face when the the pool is
not yet really established so let's
lever quick recap their Bishop b5 is a
weird move it simply does not belong
there um 11 idea is simply to go 86 as
well and asking white what he's doing I
mean this is not really helping him a
lot giving up the bishops and if he
retreats let's say I've got the move a
six extra which is on blacks agenda
anyway he and the Sicilian but okay
that's not a bad move just Knight f6 he
cancelled Bishop d6 yeah so um my
intention was and I really thought that
this is the move that he would play my
idea was to do it like that Teague's
Teague's put the bishop here and then go
a 6 that was my idea this is kind of
this kind of thing yeah the bishop has a
nice position they're interesting
position and Bishop d7 Luke c8 as
typical Sicilian play but it's a little
bit um yeah I don't know like spiced up
with that Bishop only five that's a bit
more active than having it somewhat
passively only seven but okay he made
that unfortunate f4 move and groups
that's it whenever you move the f porn
in the Sicilian you have to in the open
sign have to always look at that
diagonal so that was unfortunate and
losing and losing a whole piece check
yeah here right here there's nothing
much i actually could have taken him
yeah I didn't see that the bishop is not
really hanging as this is also a problem
but okay it's a piece and Bishop from f8
is also just winning the game okay well
guys thanks for watching